les vaccins sont à jour je venais avec
monsieur le duc aux futurs commissaires
favoriser ces parisiens ça veut dire
choisir où manger et sans chanter
tétanos
moi je suis parisien parisien ça vous
dire que quand on arrive en banlieue on
pense avoir mis les pieds au tiers-monde
attention à toi que j'ai été élevé à
auteuil auteuil qui au moyen âge était
un village populaire avec des paysans
sur toi te renseignes toi j -cv son
prestige très guitare t'excuses pas
surtout aux petits combats ils vont
jamais à l'école ici ou quoi
quand l'état mettra autant d'argent dans
les écoles ici que dans les parcs et les
jardins à paris au grain c'est bon t'as
fini qu'on aille jusqu'à alors d'accord
vous avez été dans des logements exigus
louis mais moderne alors détériorer oui
mais par qui c'est à ma mère qui m'a
fermé tant que dans sa cage d'escalier
web elle aussi on peut se plaindre
attends tu sais combien ça coûte un
loyer pour 80 mètres carrés à paris ça
qu un smic c'est combien afrique c'est
1200 euros un smic va parfaitement 2200
exactement c'est dégueulasse ouais c'est
dégueulasse absolument c'est dégueulasse
parce que moi aussi je vais pas
récupérer l'appartement de mes parents
eh ben je serai comme point dans la
galère